hello everyone and welcome to a most
violent game from the final round of the
second day of the super bed rapid and
blitz tournament currently being played
in zagreb croatia it's a rapid
tournament of course uh alireza firuja
versus shahid mahmedyarov now we've seen
the game between alireza and magnus it
was a very very intense game but uh
elereza had it all figured out and he
completely uh
nullified any uh ideas magnus might have
had in that catalan but now uh he faces
uh mamidyarov and that as as you guys
know can always be extremely dangerous
but here it's even more dangerous it's
already on move to uh mamadirov employs
a move that uh well it's not that it has
never been played before but it has only
been played uh
you know a handful of times and uh you
know for from notable games only uh
twice by fabiano caruana and the ones by
jeffrey xiong uh so now let's see wha
what what is this move so here uh
alireza opens with c4 he goes for the
english opening ponte e5 and g3 going
for the standard king's english
variation uh and now usually here you
will see knight f6 knight to c6 somewhat
rarer c6 but never or rather almost
never bishop to e7 this is what uh
mamidarov plays it doesn't have a name
officially but as fabi is
the only top player that ever played it
i'm going to call this the fabi system
of the king's english variation of the
english so here uh bishop to g2 all it
is just continues development and now
pawn to f5 again not a new position uh
uh it is a known one d for a knight to a
knight to see three or no moves but here
alireza plays b3 and it is now already
as of move 4 that we have a completely
new game and before we check out uh what
uh you know mysteries that were uh
unveiled in this
game let's just check out uh a nice
photo between these two gentlemen uh we
already seen uh alvarez's t-shirt in in
the game against magnus but here you can
see shahriar in in you know a casual
black t-shirt i thought maybe uh shock
was uh
you know trying to have uh the black
t-shirt with the black pieces and maybe
the white t-shirt with the white pieces
so i went back and checked all the
photos
but
it's not really the case he just has a
black t-shirt in all the games so if you
guys were wondering about that
but okay let's continue knight to f6 uh
we have bishop to b2 uh getting the
bishop to this nice diagonal and pawn to
d6 with e3 uh shark castles and knight
to e2 now we have c6 and alireza castles
as well we have bishop to e6 and now
knight b to c3 uh just nicely continuing
development knight b to d7 and now pawn
to d3 now getting this very nice
structure here we have queen to e8 and
now queen to d2 connecting the rooks
with king the h8 preparing to shift the
bishop over to g8 and now pawn to b4
preparing to grab more space on the
queen side with pawn to b5 so bishop g8
we have pawn to b5 and rook to c8 now so
a very very slow maneuvering game rook 8
to b1 and now striking in the center
with ponta d5 with b characters and c6
captures on c6 c captures on the e5c
captures and now pawn to f4 and here uh
my there executes uh ponte e4 uh a nicer
way to handle this was pawn to d4 but it
is uh very tricky to see why point is
that after e captures on d4 you play e4
and only after d captures an e4f
captures in the knight captures and
everything gets traded off you play
something like bishop to b4 attack the
queen uh open up a discovery in this
bishop and you can see how the white
king is completely in the open and it
will be very hard for white to defend
this position but it's a rapid game so
of course you don't expect uh
such things to be in the position uh so
here the immediate pawn to e4 and now
knight to d4 by laser going after the f5
pawn so queen to h5 defending and
activating the queen and then now comes
knight to a4 opening up the bishop's
diagonal here uh we have knight the g
for now threatening checkmate with queen
captures on h2 and already of course it
just kicks away the knight with h3
knight back to f6 and now rook beat the
c1 as the knight now lifted the c file
we are offering a trade off of rooks
here so queen to g6 putting pressure on
the g3 pawn king to h2 defending and e
captures on d3 finally
queen captures and now knight to e4 so
you could leave this knight on e4 but
it's a rapid game very little time on
the clock and this is basically a
monster night so you give up the bishop
no questions asked so bishop captures on
e4 f captures attacking the queen and
queen to b5 now going after the knight
here so rook captures on c1 rook
captures and knight the e5 this is a
beautiful move by mamidarov
if he
if he did not have this move it would be
very hard to
actually find a move here for black but
after knight to the e5 uh now alireza
has to be very very creative point is
that after if the knight is captured of
course you just get checkmated rook if
you check and it doesn't matter what you
play here uh because after you move the
king queen captures on g3 and well if
the king was on g1 it would come with
check so this would be checkmate but
even here there's really no defense
against the rook or queen to h2
checkmate so of course uh
the knight will not be captured all it
is that goes back with the queen queen
to e2 and now knight to c4 attacking the
bishop here we have bishop to a1 and now
queen to a6
attacking the knight on a4 knight the c3
attacking the pawn on d5 and now bishop
to f6 asking uh what what do you do here
so uh i hope you guys weren't
thinking of actually capturing the d5
pawn it's very easy to forget about our
good light square bishop friend here on
g8 so here knights to d1 remaneuvering
the knight to f8 then to g4 and then
we're going after the bishop on f6 we
have rook to b8 activating the rook and
now knight to f2 as planned we have
queen the a3 now with a double attack on
that e3 pawn and rook to e1 you're also
attacking the rook here but luckily we
can fix all of this by just moving the
rook to e1
rook to b6 uh we know knight the g4 is
coming this will uh put pressure on the
bishop here so we want to move the
bishop and then put the rook uh
somewhere along the sixth rank to help
out with the attack knight g4 with
bishop to e7 and now knight to f5 and
now you can see that alireza's pieces
are very very close to the black king
and with little time on the clock this
is of course extremely unpleasant that
the g7 pawn really feeling the pressure
uh so bishop back to a f8 and the now
comes bishop to d4 a beautiful
centralizing mobile it is a going after
the rook here so it comes with tempo
rook to a6 and here just rook to b1 and
now of course you can see that the
knight is coming
to maybe five also in some weird
variations maybe even the h6 uh the rook
is coming to b8 to put pressure on the
on the back rank and it's a very hard to
actually find a good move for mamidarov
here uh one thing of course you could
play here is just bishop to e6 to
eliminate one of the knights or you
could just go for a queen trade for
example queen captures the rock captures
this comes with czech king to g1 but
again uh knight e5 is coming rook to g8
is coming and it will be very unpleasant
for black to play this however if you
play it properly yeah you have nothing
to worry about so instead after rook to
b1 uh queen to d3 was played by mohammed
yarov offering a queen trade and now the
position is completely winning for
alireza but only if you find the exact
move order so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this um
you know undeniable threat and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course queen captures on d3 of
course i mean it's rook to b8 but you
can play this as you would hang your
queen so first you have to trade queens
and now rook to b8 and there is no
defense against this but it that's
easier said than done
as you'll see in the game so rook
captures an a2 with check and now comes
king the h1 now king the h1 is a draw
king the g1 is a victory here but king
to g1 is winning for reasons beyond our
wildest imagination and you would hate
me if i even tried explaining it so
let's just go king to h1
and now comes knight to d6
and now after night the d6 is played
alireza is once again winning the only
way to
save the position here is to play h5 uh
give the king a little bit breathing
room here attack the knight and now
after rook captures an f8 you cannot
capture you have to play king to h7 this
is the only way to escape certain death
and now after 97 going after the bishop
you play knight to d6 yes this is all
required just to survive this position
rook captures on g8 knights to f5 now
guarding the g7 square and now uh pretty
much everything is a draw here but
getting to this uh position uh you know
with little time on the clock in the
rapid game is impossible but now let's
say real captures knight captures uh
knight to f6 with check and now you have
a
draw by repetition because if you go to
a h8
knight to g6 will be checkmate so you
are forced to repeat here king to h6
knight after g8 with check king to h7
and knight to f6 check and so on so uh
that's the way to do it but uh after
king to h1 madera played knight to d6
and alvarez's position is once again
winning uh however not for long he plays
knight captures on g7 which is the
correct way to go uh and then now of
course you can't play bishop captures if
you play this knight h6 and you're
getting checkmated the bishop cannot
move due to the light square bishop on
d4 and uh well our next move is real
captures and g8 this will be a checkmate
so mommy darav tries knight to b5 puts
pressure on the bishop here all it is it
just moves that bishop to f6 with h5 as
we know that this is a very important
move to help out with the defense of the
black king uh but it is much too late
for such things we have knight to f5
with check sorry uh knight to f5 with
check king to h7 and now rook to b7
check f uh very nicely executed by all
it is as this is the only winning move
and then now comes bishop to f7 again a
very
nasty move to make because if you just
move the king king to g6 knights the h
for his checkmate i mean look at this
this is uh uh beautiful
uh so uh mamadirov has to start giving
up material bishop to f7 rook captures
on f7 with check king to g6 attacking
the rook and now rook captures nf8 king
captures on f5 and now alireza plays
knight to h2 as his knight is still
hanging
but this is not the path to victory the
path the victory was actually and i'm
sure you guys already see it uh you know
it's always fancy to move the knight on
the edge of the board but here it's
actually e4 and centralizing the knight
with this checkpoint being that after d
captures knight the e3 comes with check
after e6 uh we're gonna play f5 with
check king to d7 now rook to d8 with
check in once the king moves now upon g4
captures captures then we start
advancing our g pawn and we win the game
with black having uh very very little to
no counter play
but okay after king captures on f5 uh
knights the h dubai all it is uh and
even though alireza is up a piece uh it
doesn't really matter there's the past
deep one and there's the past a pawn
that uh of course already has to worry
about so pawn to d2 uh by mommy darov
and now bishop the c3 opening up a
discovery from the rook we have king to
e4 and now bishop captures on d2 alireza
has to give uh uh back the material as
uh mavidaro will bring the queen into
the game so rook capture on d2 and now
rook the e8 with check king to d3
knights to f3 now attacks the rook and
rook to d1 check king to g2 and now we
have knights to d6 attacking the rook
rook to d8 uh and interestingly knights
to d6 here uh was uh
uh was the final mistake mamidarov made
uh you have to play rook to c1 or rook
to b1 or rook to a1 or move the rook
somewhere but after knight to d6 the
position is once again winning for
alireza uh and he goes after the knight
rook to d8 attacking the knight with
knight to c4 and now rook captures on d5
king to e4 and now rook captures on b1
alireza once again blunders the win this
is incredible the this game has so many
ups and downs uh point is that here rook
c5 is winning you attack the knight and
only if the knight moves then you have
access to e5 check and then you're going
to capture this pawn for example knight
captures an e3 with check king to f2 and
now it doesn't matter what you play you
don't have this check as the knight
covers the square let's say king d3 we
play knight d1 with chuck king the d4
now rook captures on h5 and now the
pawns are winning but okay like i said
it's rapid it's a very easy to
uh point out what was missed in in the
analysis after the game so instead rook
captures and d1 was played and now again
the game is a draw knight captures an e3
with check as it comes with a fork now
most likely already just missed this
king theft knight captures on d1 with
king to e1 attacking the knight and
knight back to e3 knight to d2 with
check king to d3 and now knight to b3
now we have pawn to h4 uh busting uh
open the structure here as the three
connected pawns are much too strong so g
captures on h4 and now knight g2 check
going after the pawns king f2 we have
knight captures on h4 and the king the
g3 we have knight to f5 with check king
g4 and here comes finally the last
mistake mahmeter of makes and i'm not
even tricking you there are no more
mistakes in this game here we have to
play knight to h6 check or knight to d6
but mamidera plays knight to d4 he
offers a knight trade and all it is it
just accepts it you don't even have to
accept it you could just start advancing
the pawn
but this is much cleaner so knight
captures king captures and now f5 and
now you can see that the passport is
just much too fast if you start
advancing this pawn we just play f6 a4
uh f7 a3 f8 queen and after a2 of course
the white queen has all the time in the
world to stop the pawn like let's say
queen f2 check picks up the pawn and so
on so king the e5 was played but of
course now king to g5 and you cannot win
this race now we have a5 with pawn to f6
king the e6 now king to g6 not allowing
gank to f7 a for f7 and he was in this
position on move 68 that chakra moment
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so really really a
wild game uh momodaro i think he was
just you know completely pumped after
winning a game against magnus carlsen
and now he was uh
so much looking forward to beating
alireza with the black pieces but
alireza shows that he's a true fighter
and he takes down ahmedjarov ahmedyarov
here you resign because after a few more
moves like the king is seven king g7 a3
of course you bring a queen into the
game you pick up the pawn and then of
course it's an easy victory so yeah here
we just resign and uh for those of you
who are wondering yes these are the
standings after six rounds of the super
united croatia rapid and blitz alireza
leading the tournament with nine points
followed by with eight wesley sawyer and
jordan van forest with seven points
maxine bashar al-agra with six uh magnus
carlsen and shakhtaryan madera with five
yanipanishi linear dominguez and even
charged with four points and the
vaseline topolo with three points
so uh really really a wild game uh
mamadirov came prepared he brought this
bishop to e7 weapon to the party uh
caruana did employ it on two occasions
like we mentioned uh but um you know it
just didn't uh do all that much i mean
there were so many ups and downs uh you
know
both of them could have taken this game
uh but uh in the end it was uh you know
the third mistake that cost the money
there of the game usually in chess you
know on the top level it takes just one
but here uh took like three or maybe
even four i i stopped following after
some time
uh but yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it very nicely done by
alireza who uh was leading the
tournament after the first day and now
after the second day and that is uh even
after he faced the world champion magnus
carlsen so incredibly impressive stuff
uh i would like to thank dominic alberts
gordon merker uh tsanko solo wright
travis and michael calbert for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular tournament
until it ends
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day